this video that I'm gonna play for you
is hilarious yesterday I reported to you
the latest Fox News poll Fox which says
54% of the country wants Trump impeached
50% wants Trump impeached and removed
the team over at Fox & Friends
had some cognitive dissonance on this
one on the one hand they work for Fox
News they think Fox News is right about
the facts but they also can't believe
that anybody but the most extreme
leftists would want Donald Trump
impeached so here is video of Fox News
host Brian Kilmeade visibly stunned by
the results on the one hand it's a Fox
News poll we believe Fox News polls but
the Fox News poll says half the country
wants Trump impeached and removed how
could it be if you're watching you may
notice a perplexed look on Steve Doocy
and Ainsley Earhardt faces as well take
a look at this Fox poll came out and I
was stunned by this it says 50% of the
country want the president peached I was
stunned to see that that's the number
because I thought things were trending
away
although the president's approval rating
did take up in the same poll so it's
almost like a split personality how
could this be
say it ain't so this is what it looks
like when reality simply doesn't fit
into the Fox News narrative and again I
said this yesterday and I want to say it
again different news outlets are playing
coy with the momentum saying WOW during
impeachment hearings support for
impeachment went down usually it's like
by 2 or 3 points these polls have a
margin of error of plus or minus 3 so a
three point swing arguably means nothing
and the poll is nowhere near 50% on lots
of important internals if you look at
the same Fox News poll you see that by a
6224 margin it is wrong to ask leaders
of foreign countries to investigate
rivals that's not close that's sixty two
twenty four fifty eight to twenty two
Americans say presidents typically ask
foreign leaders to do this it should be
one hundred versus zero since clearly
it's not common Trump supporters can't
seem to admit that and are trying to use
that as a defense 50 to 236 saying Trump
isn't cooperating with the inquiry
that's very clear people understand
Trump is not cooperating here
but once again the most important thing
to remember is that these numbers
include Republicans who said in a recent
poll that Trump is a better president
than Abraham Lincoln we should actually
be shocked that only merely 50 percent
want Trump impeached and removed but
then you think back and realize Oh half
of Republicans think Trump is a better
president than Lincoln nearly two-thirds
of Republicans say they would never
abandon Donald Trump no matter what he
does then we should actually recognize
the significance of merely hitting 50%
support for impeachment despite all of
those people that are completely
disconnected from the facts and defend
Trump no matter what to the death so
sometimes the bubble of alternative
facts is so thick that people forget
there's a reality out there your
narrative isn't real that's what Brian
Kilmeade seems to be smacked in the face
with directly in this video but if it's
real enough to the people watching Fox
News it's real enough to do serious
damage to the country's ability to think
critically and that's where we find
ourselves today because really imagine
being stunned that half the country
wants the man who is arguably the most
corrupt president in the modern
presidential era removed from office for
his corruption that shouldn't be
stunning and yet somehow Brian Kilmeade
is stunned by that very backwards
situation that we are in